let's get right to the point shall we is
javascript's garbage collector as bad as
some people think it is
I have no idea so let's poke at this a
bit and see if we can learn something
basically when you allocate memory in
languages like C plus plus you have to
explicitly free it otherwise you have a
memory leak in languages like JavaScript
c-sharp Java go these are all garbage
collected languages they handle a good
chunk of the memory management for you
when you allocate some memory at some
point JavaScript has to decide when
you're done with it
so if I allocate an array here's my
array somewhere in memory and then I
fill that array with stuff so a number a
string it really doesn't matter now if I
go and null out one of the entries in
the array this little blob of memory
here kind of gets left stranded now it
has no connection to anything anymore
nothing refers to it in other words it's
not reachable if we start at a root
object we can't reach that little blob
and thus it's garbage
it's safe to reclaim that memory because
nothing can possibly be using it anymore
that's the general idea anyway let's see
it in action with some code
what I've done here is I've written a
really dumb test that just Spam fills an
object with random strings and other
objects this is called via request
animation frame kind of like you would
in a game Loop so see here I create data
set it to empty to start then I Loop
over and create a bunch of junk in there
basically a linked list of objects with
random names
and these all have to allocate memory
the strings take up memory as do the
objects themselves
this data variable isn't used anymore at
the end of each Loop so we're achieving
our goal of wasting memory and forcing
the garbage collector to act
so in order to actually test this you
need to be able to measure how much time
JavaScript spends in garbage collection
you could pull up Dev tools and hit the
performance button and dig around there
but there's actually another way that's
slightly less known
this is Chrome tracing the backbone of
Chrome's performance testing framework
hundreds of benchmarks measuring who
knows how many thousands of metrics are
built on this
in another life I was an owner here and
even led the infra team monitoring and
processing all this data it's pretty
cool you can see and attribute time to
various calls see ipcs between processes
in general it just gives way way more
info for our purposes I think it'll just
be easier to focus on what we want to
know garbage collection events
so from here you can start a Trace
choose which events you're interested in
in our case we only care about V8 stuff
and then start recording you just need
to wait a bit to capture enough of a
trace just capture however long you want
you don't need to wait to 100 percent
this uses the Doom keys to move wasd so
let's zoom in and we can look a bit
closely at all these garbage collection
events
and we can see that we were successful
at provoking the garbage collector into
action all these minor GC calls are V8
and action reclaiming memory
if we're lucky maybe we see some major
GC calls in here too
these are both versions of VH garbage
collection in action
so that brings up an important question
before we move on what is a minor GC
versus a major GC that's a good question
Simon thanks for asking that
V8 has a great blog post that talks in
depth about Orinoco their garbage
collector and goes through some of the
high level details on their collection
strategy
there's this idea the generational
hypothesis in garbage collection that
most items die really young also called
infant mortality because why not just
use super morbid terms for memory
management
but as a super hand wavy explanation V8
basically divides allocations into new
and old you have the new generation and
the old generation and in essence
allocation start in the new generation
so if I allocate a string here it starts
out in the new generation specifically
the nursery section part of this new
generation
then a garbage collection pass happens
and let's assume that some objects are
reclaimed and others aren't
if our string happens to survive the
first garbage collection attempt it gets
copied out or evacuated into a sort of
intermediate area it's not old yet but
it's not brand new either
another garbage collection event occurs
a bunch of other stuff gets reclaimed if
at that point we find that our object
survives if it's still in use it gets
evacuated out to the old generation
V8 makes this distinction so that it can
apply separate strategies for the new
and all generations
a minor GC the scavenger is optimized to
collect from the new generation while a
major GC which doesn't have a cool name
like the mutilator or anything does the
heavy lifting of sifting through the old
generation
maybe you could call it the reaper or
something
so by looking at the trace of our first
test we can actually select the first 10
seconds or so of the trace and we can
see that there were 384 occurrences with
minor GC averaging about 1.079
milliseconds each
and 56 occurrences of major DC at around
0.838 milliseconds each
so our test is getting VA to do some
minor and major GCS
so we can change this test around a tiny
bit to try and poke the major GC into
action
so what I've done here is I just take a
random subset of the data and i stuff it
into this dot stuff overriding whatever
happened to be there
this dot stuff is permanent never
deleted for the duration of the test so
this should in theory keep a bunch of
random things for a lot longer than a
single call of do something stupid and
promote things to the old generation
when we get a trace of the whole thing
and we're just going to select the first
10 seconds or so of the trace and we can
see that this is indeed what happens
we managed to force the garbage
collector to work a bit harder and we've
added some time to both minor GC and
major GC
to try and understand the relationship
between allocation patterns and minor GC
and major GC I fiddled with this a bit
more we'll try creating fewer objects
but make them more complex
this is the trace here we'll select the
first 10 seconds again and looking at it
minor GC isn't changing a whole lot but
major GC is changing quite substantially
nearly doubling the time taken versus
the simpler cases
I poke at this a bit more by adding a
setup step to the test where I just
allocate a whole bunch of random crap
and store it it's never referenced in
the test but it's there
when we look at a trace of that
we see our major GC calls getting much
more expensive
although there's fewer calls to Major GC
each invocation is taking 26
milliseconds which for a game would be
basically a skip frame something that
would be inexcusable
so that suggests that there's a
relationship between the amount of crap
you have allocated and how long the GC
takes which I mean is hardly surprising
it has to figure out what you're using
and not using it's not Magic
if you were using another language where
memory management is explicit such as C
plus it wouldn't matter how much or
literally you have allocated
there's no ongoing cost for having it
allocated you only spend time allocating
freeing
whereas in JavaScript there's definitely
like a tax on what's currently allocated
I tried a few more experiments to see if
I could make minor GCS more expensive so
what I did here was I allocated just
some random stuff in a loop
looking at the trace we did spend quite
a bit of total time in minor GCS while
time is nearly 10 percent of the time in
fact although each singular call to
minor GC was just shy of two
milliseconds so not quite the crazy long
time major GC took
I took another stab at it by allocating
sparse arrays and just randomly setting
values in there and V8 kind of laughed
that attempt off
nearly 800 minor GC calls but they ran
in a pretty negligible amount of time
I consider 10 to be pretty bad but
simultaneously it's a ridiculous setup
so maybe instead let's build a somewhat
more plausible game setup to see the
effects of GC in action
there's a quick and dirty game setup so
what I've done here is a super basic
Bare Bones game in quotation marks
I don't bother actually rendering any of
this but we do simulate the entities
so you've got this list of entities we
call update on each one when they die we
destroyed them then filter them out and
we keep a stable population by creating
new ones in their Stead the entities
themselves do some legit work so they
have a transformed data associated with
each one
along with values like energy health and
they have a spatial hashgrid client to
track their position in the world and
query other entities
they also have this update function and
then I force them to do some random
stuff I didn't feel like making the
logic extensive so I just repeat it a
few times
when they're fully charged they shoot
off a bullet so they create a bullet and
that's added to the world and bullets
are their own thing they have a full
transform their position is updated
according to Velocity and eventually
they explode and kill nearby things so
it does some stuff
I took a few traces of this running
chose a bad one and we can poke around
in here a bit
if I select the first 10 seconds or so
of the trace we can see some numbers
from minor GC in major GC
we got around 500 or so minor GC calls
taking on average less than half a
millisecond but adding up to around 240
milliseconds or so
there's not many major GC calls barely
any actually but the ones that do fire
take a little over 1.1 milliseconds each
there was always going to be some
overhead for garbage collection but at
the same time this is written super
poorly realistically an experienced game
developer will code with memory
allocations in mind
so let's make this a tiny bit better but
a slightly improved version of these
entities that attempts to minimize
allocations in the main Loop we actually
reuse entities instead of allocating new
ones and the entities themselves use
pre-allocated matrices and vectors to
perform their calculations
nothing super crazy here
looking at a trace of that version
though we can see a monster of a
difference whereas before we had around
500 minor GC calls this version gets 110
or so and a touch over 50 milliseconds
of total time spent there
is one major GC call accounting for
another millisecond of time
one really interesting thing that stands
out here is that in the first example
let's zoom in and look at these minor GC
calls they're happening during the frame
sometimes multiple times
meaning that they're contributing to
longer frames in the second example
they're happening in the idle time
between frames which is totally by
Design
V8 specifically built this feature into
Chrome when it detects there's an idle
period That's where V8 has the go-ahead
to quickly run GC
what I kind of got from all of this was
that short-lived objects are often
pretty cheap from a GC perspective
that doesn't mean they're free though
but if you can get them down low enough
they may just run in the idle time
between frames and you may not see much
in terms of overhead for it
the more crap you keep in memory the
longer lived cash stuff the more
expensive your major GCS are as we saw
with my stupid synthetic test
I know my own code though usually so
this could probably be at least
partially mitigated in the future by
just letting me tell you via some sort
of API that gives hints to the garbage
collector
something like that I don't know I've
given this a full 10 seconds of thought
you'd need to actually plan this out
more
one major problem with JavaScript though
is that although for your own app you
might be able to control your
allocations with third-party stuff you
have very little control as far as I
know
I mean in something like C plus plus
it's sort of the same deal but at least
you can override memory allocation at a
global level and depending on your
application extend this to third-party
libraries as well
in JavaScript no such luck I can't
isolate a third-party library to its own
memory pool so that's just something you
have to live with
another thing is that yeah of course
there's a cost to having GC direct
management will be more performant when
done right
but in reality decently made games don't
just allocate and free on a whim either
most do it in a very controlled way I've
spent enough time Moving Systems to
different allocation patterns linear
allocators pool allocators lifo and
scratch Pad style frame allocators in
order to ring out extra performance
C plus programmers may love to toot that
horn but even among game devs that was
usually handled by just a few people at
the studio not everyone
in JavaScript you have some control over
memory but it's pretty tenuous mostly
it's down to your pattern of allocation
minimizing allocations by reusing
objects that sort of thing
maybe you could go crazy using typed
arrays but let's save that for another
time
and lastly how much memory overhead does
JS incur for doing all of this how is
the performance on Firefox
etc etc
great questions no idea didn't test
those maybe next time
throw some comments about why you'd like
to see tested in the future until next
time cheers